and he said did you bring my bill i  didn't bring his bill and his trousers  are quite big that he doesn't like baggy  pants and the young people welcome baggy  treasure  no way they're staying up without a belt  and he's like i can't wear these and i  went hold on i've got an emergency  bracelet that in the back of the car  here i unraveled  because it was an emergency yeah i  unraveled the rope  of the key ring and it was enough to  make him a belt see so we really want to  say thank you to the people who sent us  the emergency bracelets and key rings  but me and tom have sadly lost the  letter so please if you send us  something send us an email as well so  that we can um we can look that up but  thank you very much you saved you saved  the day and you saved my son's dignity  to stroll around all day with his pants  at his ankles yes  [Music]  baby you're my  [Music]